this hello hey miss I need half it's  urgent you cannot be in here we are  don't try to steal my children I will  report you mr. Kadam for making too much  noise and I will report you for  attempted child abduction have you even  asked the boy what he wants you  deliberately seduce him they're three  for their ivory where we have multiple  vortices touching down Pete these  systems are too erratic we got to get  out of here  once we have we gotta move quickly so  you definitely need to get that last or  we could just get it first and improvise  I'll get the arm and leg send us back to  the Hashi ain't going back to hush every  time we're in nashi it's because of you  well bro won't have to worry about me  dragging you down anymore that supposed  to mean I'm coming out on my own first  chance I can we're gonna finish our  hip-hop Christmas album bro you're the  hype man he's not going anywhere we all  stick together